[Musique]
mais là il a été fondé il y a plus de
400 ans par les Portugais c'était leur
porte d'entrée en Amazonie métropole de
le principal port du delta de l'Amazone
nous
sommes encore tout près de la grande
ville mais déjà au cœur de la forêt
amazonienne
les habitants ici vivent un peu du
tourisme mais surtout des produits
naturels de la forêt
ah tu as été à derrière chez lui sa
petite plantation
il y a du cacao plusieurs de ses voisins
font du chocolat mais surtout il y a ce
long et fin palmier qui produit ce fruit
à la mode la saillie considéré comme un
super aliment acai qui veut dire le
fruit qui pleure en langage jeune toupie
qui pousse au sommet du palmier Pino est
consommé ici depuis la nuit des temps
et récolter de cette façon depuis aussi
longtemps
spectaculaire
quand il est noir il est mûr
[Musique]
je sais petites baies bleues très dur on
ne consomme que la pulpe pour soit 15 %
du fruit qu'on sépare du noyau dans ce
genre de machine
un long processus répétitif pour aboutir
à cette purée liquide qu'on vend 15 x 2
sacs un peu moins de 4 dollars c'est un
produit assez cher
consomme telle qu'elle
sorbet avec du sucre les céréales des
fruits ou encore comme une soupe avec un
peu de farine de manioc
charge sans bateau de Saïd trois ou
quatre fois par semaine et s'en va au
marché de Belek
[Musique]
à 4h du matin
tous les jours les bateaux des charges
des centaines de panier d'açaï venus des
environs les paniers de 15 kg chaque
panier se vend un peu plus de 20 dollars
un bon prix par rapport à d'autres
fruits locaux la mode ça se perd
la Saïd ont de la valeur à la forêt
amazonienne
juste à côté c'est le débarquement de la
pêche quotidienne des poissons
magnifiques énorme parfois une autre
richesse de l'Amazone ces poissons sont
transportés vers le fameux marché de
Véro réseau où ils sont rangés ausculter
Oliveira dans la journée au marché
extérieur sous forme de poisson salé
sécher et rouler avec d'autres produits
d'Amazon
notamment les noix de cajou et fameuse
noix du Brésil d'une très grande dureté
un fruit difficile à récolter dans la
forêt sauvage est difficile aussi
extraire de ses coques c'est un fruit de
grande valeur exportable et qui
témoignent de la richesse de l'Amazonie
de la nécessité de la protéger
parce qu'elle est menacé on le sait bien
maintenant la déforestation massive de
l'Amazonie le fameux poumon de la
planète favorise les changements
climatiques qui se manifeste par des
variations extrême dans les
précipitations et les période de
sécheresse mais l'apparition du variant
brésilien de la covit à Manaus montre
que l'Amazonie est vulnérable à un autre
danger plus surprenant l'apparition
d'autres virus et peut-être de pandémie
provoquées par des contacts accrue entre
les humains et la faune de la forêt
location et son groupe de chercheurs ont
été les premiers à l'ancienne alerte les
avais déjà détecté le variant 4 mois
avant qu'il soit officiellement
identifié ce n'est qu'un début et ce
sera pire quand chaîne prévient-il
le monde y a
la plus grande réserve mondiale de
coronavirus est la déforestation
intentionnellement provoquée par le
Président de la République et son
ministre de l'Environnement à Croix les
contacts de ces virus animaux avec la
population
étudier les effets de se contacter a cru
à partir des animaux quel recueil c'est
le travail de la vétérinaire de fiocruz
à Manaus Alexandre Hanna va
voir ce qui se passe quand le milieu de
la Fédérale 2 confirme
les contacts avec
par exemple
si tu
auras les moyens de de possible
parce que c'est la question nous
pourrions avoir une épidémie qui
pourrait mettre de l'Amazonie si nous
continuons à traiter la forêt et
l'Amazonie mal comme nous sommes en
train de le faire il va falloir à faire
des investissements très fort pour
protéger de
la forêt pluviale par jour avec
satellite de précision de la NASA
sont
les institutions de surveillance
affaibli tout ceci encourage les grilles
les roses les invasions illégal ça
commence par les chercheurs d'or puis
par la coupe du bois ensuite la forêt
brûlée pour en faire des pâturages
qui connaît Mick man ne vaut pas
grand-chose alors qu'une exploitation
durable de la forêt lui donne de la
valeur et donc la protège
cette compagnie 100 % Amazonia vend
exportent des produits naturels de la
forêt des fruits des doigts des huiles
des cosmétiques naturels
alors avec ce genre d'entreprise peut-on
sauver l'Amazonie
le produit vedette de 100 % Amazon hier
c'est sans surprise la salle la demande
est-elle au Brésil est dans le monde
qu'on voit de plus en plus de plantation
de palmier Pinot
celle-ci fait 18000 hectares 50.000
palmier de 8 à 10 ans qui produisent
deux fois par an 2 tonnes et demi là ça
y est on dirige l'exploitation mélange
de mets-toi de Modern comme irrigation
[Applaudissements]
c'est la récolte à l'ancienne d'escalade
du palmier en moins de 15 secondes le
propriétaire de la plantation est un
Brésilien d'origine japonaise qui en
possède deux autres semblables sur des
terres qui était auparavant des boisés
pour de l'élevage bovin comme
monoculture ce n'est pas le reboisement
idéal mais sans état et c'est peut-être
le début d'un exemple à suivre
la ça y est industrie y est les réduire
en pulpe ou en poudre dans ce genre
d'usine dans loin de Belley exporter
partout au Brésil où il est de plus en
plus consommé sa dégustation et une
petite contribution à la protection de
la forêt amazonienne